[Music]
and now we take you to Hackensack New
Jersey for a special announcement who
made this
show Chucky will return on October 4th
and I will not rest until every single
one of you [__] watch it now ask me
some questions Chucky what is this
season about all I'll say is DC is gonna
get chucked up with so much content out
there where can we watch the news it's
not too big for only one platform so my
Show's running on three USA sci-fi and
Pika next fast life well Devin Sawa be
returning as a new character next
question how about how about Jennifer
Tilly will she be back yes you know she
always comes back right here Chucky
Chucky Chucky Chucky Chuck what's your
response to critics that say there have
been way too many doll movies recently
I'd say this is not a movie I already
did seven movies this is a TV show I'm
sorry I mean kind of a shitty question
is that I'm coming for you
thank you
yeah